SCP-682 Vs SCP-165.
Could the Hard to Destroy Reptile finally
be devoured by the combined forces of the
creeping, hungry sands of tule?
A large SCP-165 sample was placed beneath
a trapdoor, with 682 positioned above it.
When the monster was dropped into the hill
of teeming, flesh-eating mites, they began
devouring it.
It was engulfed in the dune and remained in
there for ten minutes before the dune ceased
activity, and a much smaller version of SCP-682
crawled out.
The Fire Eaters were called in to blast both
and return 682 to its containment chamber.
In all likelihood, 682 had emitted a pesticide
that killed off the mites, while a smaller
version of itself hid inside its own skull
until it was safe to emerge and attempt escape.